like
have you ever written a distance do you
have any diss tracks
do you have you had any beefs like have
you gotten into that negative [ __ ]
in the rap world at all i think i think
i'm the mo
the only person i've been super negative
towards is probably myself
right just as a human being and as an
artist
feeling like a fraud um and i
and before i answer that question i'll
go on to say i've i actually discovered
what my talent is the other day it hit
me like a ton of bricks my talent is
finding
more talented people and smarter people
than i am putting them in a room and
telling them what the [ __ ] to do
so that i look good um that's a joke
but it's actually kind of nice when it
comes to when it comes to the negative
aspect of
rap and hip-hop i've had more beefs
thrown my way
than a [ __ ] slaughterhouse like i i
don't know damn that's a good punch line
right there write that down
um but i've never really responded
you know um i had this i just beef with
this guy named joyner lucas
um i love how oh [ __ ]
he's calling you right here
i don't think she really i don't think
she realizes i'm doing this
sorry okay can you guys can you hear me
yeah yeah no worries
all right can you see me okay good i
apologize um so
uh i had a um a beef with this guy named
joyner lucas
phenomenal rapper great rapper and um
he just didn't like me um and he was
saying all types of [ __ ]
he was like because you know i'm
biracial i'm black and white and i like
you know let that be known that my dad
is black and my mom is white
and not because i wanted to be like
accepted by any community or this or
that but because
when everyone's calling you white but
you grew up in a black family it's like
right [ __ ] off like at least call me
what i am
but that's neither here nor there anyway
he would like make fun of me for [ __ ]
like that who and he himself was
biracial
and um yeah he just talked a whole bunch
of [ __ ] and i just ignored him and i
ignored him and i ignored him and kept
talking [ __ ] he kept talking [ __ ]
and uh i just let it go and i didn't
give a [ __ ] then one day
i got a call that he wants to get on the
phone and apologize and he does and i
won't go into too much detail
because that was between me and him as
men but what he said was
he was sorry and he was wrong
and um i said it's okay you're my
brother you know like we're this is
hip-hop
and thank you and that was it and then
we went on to make this [ __ ] song
that just went platinum and
i said so so any anytime i have
beef throwing my way i just don't
respond and it's kind of like a thing
that's known
in rap now like logic's never gonna
respond to you because
the [ __ ] is beneath me bro now that
doesn't mean that these people are
beneath me
the negativity is beneath me because i'm
the type of [ __ ] that's like i
got guns if i don't like you and you're
talking about you want to kill me i'll
[ __ ] you up you know what i mean like
i i that's how i feel if you're coming
at my life you're coming at my family
i'll [ __ ] bleed out to protect me
and them so if somebody's coming at me
on some rap [ __ ] i'm like
no like you know i'm not gonna go there
um because then [ __ ] can get real
and i know that because i know what real
hip-hop beef is founded and has been
founded on
but when somebody's trying to use your
name for a little bit of cloud or
whatever
more power to them i wish them the best
and i have nothing to say
and nothing to give them but my love
though they may
be too ignorant to understand that we
are just brothers
in the same you know genre of music
yeah dude